This is the beginning
it's the best marvel series ever
it's really amazing
now on disney plus don't miss steve what did
you do the global phenomenon we have a deal
promise no secrets between
called us wish i could
marvel studios moon knight new episode
streaming wednesdays only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my moon
knight episode 5 trailer video there's a whole
bunch of marvel easter eggs we'll break down i'll
explain what's going on with the hippo goddess
showing up at the end of episode four the mental
hospital jake lockley and omit being unleashed on
the main mcu dimension because it's only gonna get
crazier in the last two episodes if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter just be
a subscriber and leave your favorite easter egg
or your big question on the video careful for
spoilers from everything through moon knight
episode 4 if you haven't seen the episodes yet too
because we'll be talking about everything that's
happened so far at the end of episode four while
marc spector was in control of the body arthur
harrow shot him twice after he'd found the stone
figure of ahmed that the other gods had trapped
her in 2000 years ago it's the same type of stone
figure that we just saw khonshu get trapped in by
the other gods and they also revealed that there
were many other gods from their pantheon that were
trapped inside the great pyramid there's a lot of
brand new footage inside that great pyramid area
that we saw during episode three and it seems like
it's connected to ahmet in khonshu coming back
like any time you see giant purple smoke or
purple power anywhere even though it does look
like agatha harkness's purple power technically in
the context of moon knight that means it's amid's
power most of the time in the marvel productions
like marvel phase 4 movies disney plush shows they
try to color code things so that when people are
using different types of power they use different
colors to denote where they're getting their power
from that they are different types of power like
chaos magic is red loki's magic is color-coded
green because it uses a different type of magic
so on so forth but during episode four there were
some really big twists some really big left turns
in the story so we found out that alexander
the great of the mcu was amit's former avatar
and during that period he was the one who rebelled
against her he was the pharaoh at the time so
after conquering the known world using her power
they kind of imply that he was able to be so great
quote-unquote do all these great things because
he was the avatar of one of the gods he had godly
power but apparently at the end of his lifespan
after he conquered most of the known world that's
when he learned what amit's plan for the rest of
the mcu dimension was and that's when he rebelled
against her but because there is this brand new
footage of arthur harrow inside the great pyramid
of giza with all this purple power billowing
everywhere it seems like that place is connected
to her coming back and we'll see some of that
happen during episode five because the minute that
his body spilled into that water arthur harold
probably reached out and grabbed the figurine of
ahmet and started continuing to try and bring her
back to release her from that stone figure there
is some footage of both of them flying at each
other with their powers activated like you see
him in the moon knight costume and you see arthur
harrow using his power of omit and they're having
a more traditional superhero battle like you would
see during civil war with everybody flying at each
other that implies that at some point khonshu
will be free again or he finds a workaround
that allows him to use the power of khonshu i'll
explain that too because technically khonshu was
trapped in the stone figure so you think that he
would be completely cut off from his power like
they made this big thing in the episode about
him not having the healing powers the healing
factor that he got from the suit but if ahmed has
been trapped in the same type of stone figure for
the last 2000 years then how is arthur harrow able
to become her avatar and use her power in present
day while she's been trapped so if arthur harrow
can use her power while she's trapped that also
means that marc spector and steven grant the other
personalities like jake lockley can also probably
use the power of moonite and khonshu when khonshu
is trapped they just haven't realized it yet
a lot of you are asking about that too like wait
a minute ahmed's been trapped this whole time if
alexander the great was the last avatar then if
she's been trapped how is arthur harrow able to
become her new avatar that's just a clue for marc
spector realizing how he's still connected to
khonshu even though khonshu was trapped in that
stone figure that's also one of the reasons why
the hippo goddess probably showed up to help
explain what's actually going on we also got
pretty good confirmation on jake lockley being
a thing on the show and he'll just be the next
personality maybe in episode five that we actually
see on screen they did make it seem like we would
actually see him at some point during episode 5.
they hinted at him with a couple huge easter eggs
so far the scene from episode 4 where he passed
that banging person in the sarcophagus was really
meant to be obvious though back in episode 3 both
steven and marc don't know who killed the men with
a knife and it happened after another blackout
jump in time right after marc spector had stiffed
a cabbie to chase him down steven what did you do
i swear it wasn't me then who was it jake lockley
in the comics was originally a gruff cab driver
persona of marc spector so they're really trying
to bang you in the head with the idea that jake
lockley persona is going to surface on the show
and apparently he is way stabbier than marc
spector and steven grant and he has some of
the same skills as marc spector a lot of you now
asking what's going to be different about the
jake lockley persona though like marc spector is
supposed to be the fighter he's the mercenary the
person who's more of a traditional superhero type
that's why when they're in the regular moon knight
costume it's always him in control of the body
and when it's steven grant they switch back to the
actual suit and tie version of the costume does
that also mean that it'll be another third type of
moon knight costume when he's in the jake lockley
persona if they're trying to be really accurate to
the comics that means no they've already changed
the comics a little bit but the whole idea is
that when he's in moonlight persona he isn't marc
spector persona jake lockley is just someone that
he uses to gather information when he's dressed
in plain clothes the reason why he created jake
lockley in the comics was to gather information
from people on the streets who normally
wouldn't reveal things to a millionaire playboy
philanthropist steven grant take that off what are
you genius billionaire playboy philanthropist so
for example the reason why jake lockley was a cab
driver persona is because people will just talk to
cab drivers without thinking too much about them
that's why when they hint to jake lockley he stabs
all those people and then when he's acting as
marc spector the guy won't tell him and he kills
himself by allowing himself to fall off the cliff
i've made the batman reference before he's kind
of like the matches malone version of marc spector
same thing on the moon knight series which is why
i don't think we're gonna get like a third version
of a moon knight costume as many toys as they
do want to sell like if they did create a third
different version of a moon knight suit people
would totally rush out and buy it that's one of
the other funny things about the tv show too right
after episode 4 aired they actually released the
actual marvel action figures so like you could
run out and buy this moon knight action figure
that you see during the episode it's a little
more obvious during the star wars movies and
the star wars disney plus tv shows like look at
this really cool thing oh yeah we have a toy for
that we're releasing right now rush out and buy
it right now just you wait for marvel to release
secret wars is gonna be a toy bonanza people are
gonna go crazy spending money on new toys so jake
lockley will probably just be the more worldly
persona who's really quick to violence too marc
spector also seems like he doesn't enjoy killing
people and jake lockley has no problem in doing
it like i'll stab every single one of you until
you give me this information the whole thing with
them doing the hippo goddess on the show like
they have that big twist at the end of episode
four where they freak out yes that is the actual
mcu version of the goddess that they're seeing
in their head at the end of the episode remember
they're in the mind space right now so that's
why they're seeing her true depiction even though
she and the other gods that are part of conscious
pantheon including khonshu are technically
trapped outside the main mcu dimension in
this pocket dimension her name is tawaret they
referenced her during episode 1 when steven was
talking about all the different plushies of the
gods so when she shows up raising her hand inside
his head or inside their head however you want
to think about it and she's happy to be there
like happy to see them as if it's no big deal
like this is a common thing like hey what's up
when i talked about next week's episode i talked
about them taking a magical mystery mindspace tour
the actress who plays this hippo goddess said that
her goddess represented fertility and birth she's
viewed as more of a kindly gentle god dealing with
the soul the mind and what they're probably having
her do on the show based on all the footage that
we see is during episode five some of the footage
you see is mark spector's backstory like more
flashbacks showing him becoming moony for the
first time making that initial bargain with
khonshu at the foot of his statue so for at
least some of the episode next week he'll still be
trapped in that mind space between life and death
trapped in his own mind and just like the comic
book run of him being trapped in the headspace
version of the mental hospital they'll use his
journey with the hippo goddess through his past to
sort of deal with his past trauma and explain how
all the different personas actually became a thing
like i said too they'll also probably hint at
the idea that he still has access to khonshu
even though technically kanchi was trapped in the
stone figure because if arthur harrow has access
to amit and she's been trapped this whole time
then that means that marc spector probably has
access too there were some of you that were also
confused about kang the conqueror in the episode
he wasn't physically in the episode like people
saw the mental hospital and this figure sitting
next to donna his character's name on the show
is rostler he was one of arthur harrow's men
that we saw previously in episode four kang and
his variants as far as we know are all played by
jonathan majors i know everybody's hoping to see a
version of iron lad who's technically played by a
different actor who would be a version of kang in
his youth but the only king to conquer easter eggs
that we've seen so far in the moon knight series
are just the connection to the great rift why the
gods initially left the mcu and kane coming back
in time to rule over ancient egypt as rama tut
long before alexander the great and before what
happened with ahmet being trapped in the stone
but if you spotted any brand new easter eggs
in the trailers that i didn't talk about in the
video just write them below in the comments my
full episode 5 video will post next week after
they release it i've got new doctor strange 2 in
thor love and thunder videos that i'm working on
those will post really soon make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss those
congratulations raven chang you're the giveaway
winner from my last big video please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can get your
contact details everyone click here for my full
moon knight episode 4 video and click here for my
full thor love and thunder trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!